losing the icon who was Prince was tough
he changed music he challenged how
masculinity and sexuality intertwine in
pop culture and well he just made some
pretty damn good songs but Prince's
death from an overdose on opioids really
underscored a tragic reality facing more
and more Americans every year i'm sunnah
this is a j+ and today i want to talk
about america's growing opioid addiction
and how those responsible are the ones
who are supposed to help us now lots of
beloved celebrities names we know names
we listen to faces we've watched have
struggled with opioid addiction and in a
few well-known cases we didn't know
until it was actually too late like
Prince the man was known for his
theatrics on camera off camera and on
stage he brought a lot of energy into
his performances he loved to jump around
and do splits and while it looked
awesome it wasn't so hot for his body
especially his hips so to deal with the
pain Prince started prescription
medication and he continued to use that
medication well after his hip surgery
years ago and it's pretty hard to know
for sure but most folks think it's
during that period that his addiction
began an addiction that led to his April
2016 death when he was found in his
Minnesota home dead from an opioid
overdose now it's easy to look at prints
and think well big star lots of fame may
be susceptible to an addiction but
here's the thing Prince's story of
addiction and his death is one of
hundreds of thousands in this country so
many people out there have strikingly
similar stories stories that begin with
a doctor's prescription and end with
either rehab or an overdose started
getting pain pills not for myself from
the doctor I started shooting that I
became an IV drug user when he sent me
to rehab I was thinking my gosh I'm not
an addict you know I couldn't wake up in
the morning and shave unless I had a
pain pill for example it's estimated
that at least 7 million people have
abused oxycontin a name you probably
recognize since it's the most well-known
famous painkiller and it doesn't just
end up using painkillers overdoses are
happening in every corner of the country
there have been over 190,000 deaths in
less than 20 years so what we're seeing
happen
this country is nothing short of a
health crisis and that's surprising and
concerning because this health crisis
actually originates from within our
health care system like it originates
from the pharmaceutical companies and
the doctors who treat us alright so
here's how it goes
painkillers aren't new they've been
around for a long time but for the most
part their use was limited to treating
serious pain like terminally ill with
cancer kind of pain then in the 90s drug
companies saw an opportunity and thought
well why not expand the market by
treating other types of pain like broken
bones and back pain that makes for more
types of pain more people and so more
money and painkillers our opioids which
are drugs that interact with your brain
and nervous system which create a sense
of pain relief and pure euphoria and the
pharma industry is big on making opioids
like oxycontin Percocet vicodin and
fentanyl but as we all know heroin also
chemically follows the same family
meaning painkillers are doing to your
mind and body what heroin can do because
of the addictive nature of opioids
doctors restricted their use and
prescription so the drug companies
especially Purdue Pharma who makes
oxycontin undertook a marketing campaign
to convince doctors that they could
prescribe your painkiller more widely
because they had made it less addictive
and for the record they had it and this
campaign worked like really worked a
Johns Hopkins study found that within
five years the amount of painkillers
prescribed almost doubled Purdue made
money and continues to make a lot of
money doctors over prescribing
painkillers each year they see another
three billion dollars in revenue mostly
thanks to oxycontin and it's paying
offered them in a personal way - in 2015
the family that owns Purdue the settlers
became one of the 20 richest families in
America that's even though in 2007 the
company's marketing of oxycontin
attracted the attention of the US
Department of Justice the company along
with three of its executives were
charged with misleading doctors on the
addictiveness of the drug they settled
the case for six hundred and thirty five
million dollars but that was ten years
ago and the ruling did surprisingly
little to curb the number of
prescriptions written for oxycontin in
2014 alone over 5 million scripts were
given out so unsurprisingly this problem
this crisis isn't going anywhere anytime
soon
I wish I would have known how addicted
that they really were and the you know I
was being prescribed a lot more than
what I could have ever possibly needed
could say that I would wish that
somebody able to tell me that you know
that there was hope I felt like that I
was the one person out of a million that
lived a different lifestyle um that not
everybody out there went through the
things that I've been through in fact a
recent report from Centers for Disease
Control stated that quote the opioid
overdose epidemic is worsening the rate
of prescription drug related overdoses
has tripled since 2000 in 2014 the same
year that five million oxycontin
prescription for in more people died of
drug overdoses than car accidents
opioids which includes both prescription
painkillers as well as heroin accounted
for the majority of those deaths and
it's important to not separate heroin
from those prescription painkillers lots
of folks who are getting addicted to
pills are turning to heroin once they
can't get a prescription anymore it
gives you the same euphoria and it's
much cheaper and you don't need a
doctor's note and the link between
heroin and painkillers is an anecdotal
the CDC has said that quote past misuse
of prescription opioids is the strongest
risk factor for heroin initiation and
youth and that the nationwide increase
in heroin is closely tied to dependence
on pain relievers in other words there
is widespread agreement that one the
drug companies lied about how addictive
their pills were and two that the
prescribing of oxycontin in particular
is responsible for both the abuse of
prescription painkillers and a surge of
heroin use in recent years so this story
is really big and it's really
complicated tell us what you guys want
to know what did we miss what do you
want to learn more about and do you know
anyone maybe who might have an opioid
addiction let us know in the comments
and don't forget to Like subscribe and
share